the summer of 2008 Commerce Bank has big
plans for the future its directors want
to take over Germany's third largest
financial institution the drezna bank
for nine billion euros but then the
financial crisis hits commercial banks
share prices go into freefall but it's
too late to stop the takeover the
purchase and losses caused by the crash
drive the back to the edge of bankruptcy
the German government has to step in
Commerce Bank receives over 16 billion
euros in state funds and is partially
nationalized its share price recovered
slightly the bank wants full
independence back as soon as possible
in April 2011 it pays the government
back fourteen point three billion euros
of the money owes but the bank shares
are now penny stocks
and the ECB's fitness test show Commerce
Bank is low on capital to stock up its
war chest it has to issue fresh stock
but companies which share prices under
Euro can't do that so the bank gets
around the rule by bundling ten shares
into one and selling them as a package
that raises the share price tenfold
although the improvement is largely on
paper